humans must remain the stewards of
creation we can't just delegate that
away like the Congress delegated away so
many of its powers to the alphabet
agencies in the executive branch we
cannot just delegate away our
stewardship of the creation to a
computer
we cannot establish the domination of
Technology over the origin and Destiny
of human life this is one of the strong
arguments against in vitro fertilization
one of the arguments against things like
in vitro fertilization there are many
arguments but one of which is it
establishes the domination of Technology
over the origin and Destiny of human
life it disrespects our own humanity and
we as as people who were made in the
image and likeness of God that is a huge
threat there is always a political
battle between policies that will
degrade human beings or policies that
will recognize the Dignity of human
beings